BUT BEFORE WE GO TONIGHT, I WANT
TO KEEP IT 100, BUT I'M NOT
GOING TO ANSWER A QUESTION.
I'M JUST GOING TO MAKE A QUICK
STATEMENT ABOUT THE RIOTS AND
LOOTING GOING ON IN BALTIMORE
TODAY.
THERE'S A LOT OF ANGER AND A LOT
OF FRUSTRATION IN THE COMMUNITY
OVER WHAT SEEMS TO BE A RASH OF
POLICE KILLING UNARMED BLACK
MEN.
BUT THE ANSWER IS NOT LOOTING
AND RIOTING OR RANDOM ACTS OF
VIOLENCE.
LET'S NOT FORGET, IT WAS ACTS OF
VIOLENCE THAT GOT US HERE IN THE
FIRST PLACE.
THE EVENTS ARE STILL UNFOLDING,
SO I CAN'T GET TOO SPECIFIC.
BUT THERE IS ONE THING THAT I
KNOW FOR CERTAIN WHEN IT COMES
TO FREDDIE GRAY -- THIS IS NOT
THE WAY TO HONOR THIS YOUNG
MAN'S LIFE, ESPECIALLY ON THE
DAY OF HIS FUNERAL.
GOODNIGHTLY EVERYONE